galacto borreco and baklava are
traditional Greek desserts although
several European and Middle Eastern
countries have versions of baklava most
consist of phyllo pastry filled with
nuts drenched in Honey or syrup galacto
borreco is phyllo filled with custard
and coated with sweet syrup this variety
of baklava called Burma is made not with
phyllo dough like classic baklava but
with kataifi shredded wheat dough Burma
like classic filo baklava contains whole
pistachios never pistachio powder
this Burma Chef pours granulated sugar
over the pistachio kernels
next he sprinkles rose water although
this ingredient is optional then syrup
made with sugar water cinnamon and
Nutmeg as well as lemon to prevent the
sugar from later crystallizing
he mixes by hand to thoroughly coat the
kernels
[Music]
itaifi is made of all-purpose flour milk
and water
[Music]
the chef lays out a section of dough
then takes a handful of pistachio
filling and places it on the dough
forming a line running down the middle
for a Burma loaf this size The Filling
is about an inch wide and high
[Music]
he folds the end closed and rolls the
dough at an angle down the length of the
Burma tightly encasing the filling as he
goes
[Music]
at the end he folds the opposite end
closed it takes a Burma Chef months to
perfect this technique
he places it on a tray to air dry for 24
hours to ensure the dough maintains its
rolled shape
unlike classic baklava which is baked
Burma is fried and the risk of burning
the pistachios makes this the most
technically challenging type of baklava
to make the chef fries the loaves for
three minutes in oil heated to around
350 degrees Fahrenheit turning them once
per minute
he lets the oil drain off for half an
hour
then he pours warm caramelized sugar
over the Loaves and lets them soak for
20 minutes
the sugar to water ratio and the boiling
time of the caramelized sugar have to be
just right otherwise it will become
either too hard or too gooey when it
cools
after letting the excess drain off the
loaves rest for about three hours
then the chef rolls the loaf to flatten
out the bumps and slices it into equal
pieces
but if there's a protracted battle
waging between your sweet tooth and your
willpower
we've got plenty of time to work your
way through a box of Burma because it
stays fresh for two weeks
[Music]
to make galactober Echo the chef begins
with two ingredients
milk and Semolina
after bringing the milk to a boil he
gradually adds the semolina while
whisking and lowering the temperature
once the mix thickens he sets it aside
to cool
in a separate Bowl the chef whisks eggs
adds vanilla
then lemon or orange rind other options
are orange blossom or rose water extract
he transfers the ingredients to an
electric mixer adds butter and sugar
then he adds the semolina and milk
mixture
this mixture must be cool so that the
eggs don't cook
once everything is Thoroughly Blended
the galacto-barreco custard is ready
the chef now turns his attention to the
phyllo dough he Stacks 24 parchments in
sheets of phyllo and slices them into
squares
he places one scoop full of Custard in
the center of each Square the
traditional Greek way is to roll the
squares or bake a large galacto pereco
in a pan and then cut it into squares
however this Chef folds over each Square
to make Lebanese style triangles
he douses the top with clarified butter
butter that's been boiled to separate
out the solids and leave just the oil
then he bakes the pastries for 45
minutes at 325 degrees Fahrenheit
the golden Big Top shines thanks to the
clarified butter
the chef Cooks the same syrup he made
for The Baklava sugar water cinnamon
nutmeg and lemon and generously drizzles
the mixture All Over The colectober
Echoes he sprinkles on cinnamon for
traditional flavor and some crushed
pistachios for decoration
the annual apple harvest is just two
months long to keep apples fresh in
storage for several months Growers lower
the storeroom oxygen level to put the
apples into hibernation then they use
machines called CO2 scrubbers to absorb
and remove the carbon dioxide gas the
apples give off this CO2 scrubber pulls
air from the airtight apple storage room
through carbon pellets which absorb the
CO2 gas molecules
the machine then blows the CO2 free air
back into the room
workers build the machine's frame out of
tubular steel the frame supports all the
components including two sealed vessels
filled with carbon pellets the first
vessel starts absorbing CO2 a process
called scrubbing until its pellets are
saturated then the second vessel takes
over the scrubbing the first vessel
automatically kicks into a regeneration
cycle which blows fresh air through the
pellets
to remove the CO2 molecules and exhaust
them out the building when the second
vessel's pellets max out vessel 1
resumes scrubbing while vessel 2
regenerates
to construct each vessel workers weld a
steel sheet into a circular shape
then weld on a base and a top Ring The
Ring has holes along its perimeter for
bolting on a lid they use a ring
template to make corresponding holes in
the lid
making the exact center of each hole
with a punch tool
then a worker mounts the lid on a
fixture and following those marks uses
an automated steel punch to perforate
the steel
[Music]
missiles go to the paint booth for a
coat of powder paint
then into an oven to bake the paint when
they come out the vessels are ready to
be filled with carbon pellets and seal
[Music]
once filled to the top workers lay in a
steel baffle
its holes evenly distribute air passing
through the vessel
a worker then places a foam rubber
gasket around the perimeter
and bolts on the lid tightly
this seals The Vessel and prevents the
air being blown through it from leaking
out the sealed lid also prevents oxygen
from getting into the machine and from
there into the apple storage room next
workers install the PVC piping that
feeds air through the vessels along with
two blowers
one blower pulls air from the apple
storage room into the machine for
scrubbing
the other sends it back to the room
after scrubbing
airflow through the pipes is controlled
by valves which are wired to the
machine's electrical panel
that electrical panel consisting of
relays pumps gas analyzers and a touch
screen is built in-house
ordinance with the required electrical
standards of the customer's country
the panel is wired to a computer which
controls the entire operation
[Music]
then a worker installs an electrical box
into the machine's frame
[Music]
and he installs the electrical panel
Inside the Box
foreign
next the worker connects the wires to
the valves installs the touch screen and
hooks it up to the computer the touch
screen lets the machine's operator
program oxygen and CO2 Target levels
specific to the type of apple stored in
the room this is critical as different
varieties of apples give off more CO2
than others
how does it all work the grower Stacks
bins of apples in an airtight store room
a nitrogen generator feeds in nitrogen
to reduce the room's oxygen level to 1.8
percent
when that happens the nitrogen feed
automatically stops and the continuous
CO2 scrubbing automatically begins
many Growers have in-house Labs which
conduct quality control tests on samples
taken from each lot of scrubbed apples
coming out of storage
no apples would pass these tests after
the two-month harvest season if not for
the CO2 scrubbers
CO2 scrubbers lengthen an Apple's
freshness by about eight months making
it possible to bite into crispy apples
year round